[Music]
hello south by southwest
thank you all so much for joining us
we're really thrilled to have most of
the gang back together for a fun virtual
script read of
last season's episode the retracer
stabilizer the finale of season one
and this is a great way to get set for
season two which will be dropping on
march 26th
only on hulu yeah so watch all of season
one get it all in your brain
right in time for march 26th you can
dive into season two and boy the
surprises that await you
hey wait a minute justin yeah you know
before we play the table read
would you be okay if we played a little
uh sneak peek of a clip
from season two an exclusive clip no
no no dude come on no let him do it i'm
sorry i'm putting my foot down on this
one
all right cool cool cool guys play the
clip
this is camp no don't be dumb it's much
much deeper in the woods okay guys
remember we parked by trees
[Music]
halt this is camp good-bye we're leaving
good luck
it looks the same as where we parked
yeah this just feels like the regular
old woods where's
cam we talked to our creepy
neighbor for almost five minutes about
this so i know
for sure that this is camp we leave you
here for two or three weeks you learn to
swim or some and then we come pick
you up the end
cool works for me we'll visit over
parents weekend okay bye no we won't
terry are you sure the car is this way i
took four units of pathfinding at the
academy to prepare for life on dangerous
alien
worlds i think i can walk us out of the
woods
[Music]
what the terry just admit it we're
locked it's just up here i promise
camp sucks there's not even a flag to
capture hey how long does it take to
sexually awaken
i whittled a boyfriend to grind on you
know for when it happens
this is nate jacobs we met at his bark
mitzvah can we just go home
yes except we're lucky i knew it all
because you couldn't stop drinking those
stupid tiki drinks that's stupid
i find my way out of the woods better
when i'm drunk you ever even had any of
these this one's from a coconut
oh how can we possibly be lost we have
access to the most sophisticated
tracking equipment in the quadrant we
left it in the car okay we're gonna be
trapped here until we die and i'll never
get to have a 500 days of summer quirky
romance with a manic 50 dream bowl
everybody calm down i'm an expert
trailblazer we just have to follow the
dimmest star it'll always lead directly
south
all the stars are dim on this stupid
planet why is there a branch through my
shoulder because you
said if we didn't eat soon you were
going to ram a branch through your
shoulder and that was six weeks ago all
right
yeah i guess i'm in shock all right
everybody welcome to
solar opposite south by southwest table
read episode 108 it's our season finale
from the first year
it's called the retracer stepalizer
written by ariel shepard oppenheim and
joe saunders
we're super excited to have our whole
cast here playing corvo justin roiland
terry thomas middleditch hello hello
thank you
you like ann funnylack sean jimbroni
yeah thank you see the amazing mary mac
the pupa today is our co-creator mike
mcmahon
playing vambo is the one and only jason
mandzukic and he's also going to be
playing some other characters
and the amazing kari walgreen is going
to be playing a bunch of different
characters for us
aisha terry lorraine jacqueline tiny
voice from geode she's amazing
uh and the amazing eric bowser is also
stepping in for us to do a bunch of
roles as well
todd giant face panic zone schlorpian
will be doing the stage direction my
name is josh beisel and i matter
the least of all all right no no
into the cold open tearing corvo's house
living room terry stands next to
elliptical machine
lightly pulling on one bar with one hand
and holding a tablet computer in the
other a movie
plays on the screen which we don't see
you are no longer
abraham lincoln us president you
are now abraham lincoln car fighter
yes okay let's go jerry orville
walks in looking annoyed he's carrying
the pupa who's usually yellow but is now
glowing orange
can't talk working out this is important
the the the pupa turned orange
and hey you broke my hulu beast cuba is
not supposed to be orange
it's pantone 101c what does it mean
how the hell am i supposed to know
because it's your job terry
i fixed the ship you take care of the
pupa right yes okay that is my job
fair once this thing evolves to its
ultimate form it'll consume everything
on the planet and terraform
it to become our new home world which
means we'll be eaten and terraformed
with everything else i
i think what if it turning orange is the
first step to total annihilation
wait uh i i think it feels hot is that
important
no it's always hot luckily i'm a genius
and suspected you were incapable of
handling this so i made a little card
with important pupil information on it
i have it in my wallet and you just just
gotta find it damn it where did i put my
when was the last time i needed sloppy
money to pay for something
was it at the armenian delhi it was on
shore but the homeworld blew up in the
opening credits
which leaves us no choice i must use the
retrace your stepalizer device to travel
back in time
return to the home world and find my
wallet dramatic sting
yeah i'm gonna pass that sounds like a
lot of work and the pupa's never killed
anybody on earth before so
it's gonna blow
so uh where's the retruce von something
geyser does it look like a spaceship
with a big clock on the back
retrace your step elizor it's high-tech
shoes that allow the wearer to travel
back in time to places they've stood in
the past
these things cost 11 billion dollars a
shoe ooh
do they light up mine do oh that's so
rad oh
why do you get the cool ones because i'm
in charge the retracer stepalizer has a
specific set of instructions
failure to comply could result in a
catastrophic outcomes for space time
continue
jesus
failure to comply could result in a
this is me at the records always adding
words
always like yeah failure to comply could
result in catastrophic outcomes for the
space-time continuum do you understand
terry
shoes with rules got it rule number one
while using the retrace your stabilizer
no one in the past will be able to see
or hear us two we can only stay in the
past for eight hours or we'll turn into
slime
three we can't learn anything new we
didn't already know or will turn into
slime
four if we walk too fast we'll turn into
slime five
if we do double back flips we'll turn it
to slime continues talking but his voice
fades in the background we hear terry's
thoughts
note to self the pretzel bite is the
most
underrated appetizer someone just say
something to whoever's making those
stinky old menus
those pesky menus some of them are too
long
too many items that's why i don't eat
chinese no other reason
menu are you listening to me terry
yeah yeah yeah yeah slime keep going we
go to the ship on taran corvo's house
jessie exits a room on the ship closing
the door but it bounces open she walks
off his yummy like turns to the corner
jesse oh you left the pretendo deck open
again
welcome back to the pretender deck
yomulac hey aisha play the last program
that jesse was running
well it's an invasion of her privacy
don't you think yeah that's why it's
going to be awesome
override protocol password panera bread
with threes for each override accepted
resuming last program you little creep
room shimmers and shifts and a hologram
of yummy like appears
hello jesse i'm funny lack want to
continue our awesome makeover montage
we left off on a cowboy outfit what the
hell
is this what are you supposed to be i'm
funny lag
i'm exactly like you but funner and
nicer and i know how to braid and bake
bread
jessie's got a nicer mean here that's
impossible every time i walk into a room
someone says oh
great hello well jesse thinks you're a
dick
she said one time oh oh oh he tried to
trade me to a witch
for a ps4 yeah but she wouldn't take it
take the deal
you can't complain about almost being
traded to a witch
he makes fun of the way i walk and
breathe
come on have you ever watched her walk
it's all clog clop clock gasp gasp
i like the way she walks shoot me i
think it's elegant
then why don't you two get married i
wish
oh gross this is messed up i'm super
nice
i guess i'll have to force jesse to like
me with craig t
and porvo's walking around still
explaining the rules on the ship
rule 58 don't fall in love with anyone
in the past or will turn into slime
are you sleeping ah don't touch anything
are we turning this line
i wish we could touch stuff in the past
but it doesn't work like that it's more
like
we're ghosts then how are we getting
your wallet we'll have to use the
retouch your stuffalizer a heavily
enforced vault opens revealing a gray
stick with a spork fixed to the end with
scotch tape
oh jesus wow that came from the
homeworld ah kind of just looks like a
stick with a spork
you know you're supposed to get a
license to use these but that office
blew up so we should be fine
and now it's time to retrace our steps
[Music]
ah beautiful schlorp oh how i miss this
wonderful strict totalitarian place
it's a lot smaller than i remember oh i
never thought i'd see my old quarters
again oh god
i made love to a lot of equations in
here you
math rad it's young you
damn girl you used to be way skinnier ah
seriously stand next to yourself see the
difference
you have let yourself go look you left
the wallet on the table oh that's
perfect terry
i will now use the stick to hit the
wallet into our ship
at the spaceport it should be in the
ship when we return to the present
are you missing on purpose just to make
me giggle it's working
stop watching me don't watch me do this
we go back to earth
we go to lorraine's house she is an
elder woman sitting alone in an armchair
in her living room knitting
oh hello little one would you like a
stale cookie from a rusty tin
oh we go into the white space we are now
in a white empty void lorraine looks
around totally freaked out
where am i are we dead good afternoon
lorraine
i know that you've lost many things over
the years your children moved away your
husband is gone even your friends have
died
all you have left are your memories this
is your chance lorraine
i can access your mind and show you
anything you've ever seen
is there something you've lost that you
can't remember which i can give you
i can't remember the face of my mother
i just wish i could see her one last
time
we catch glimpses of how slurp is
preparing for the impending asteroid
businesses have signs up front saying
the apocalypse here everything half off
oh terry everyone is so relaxed even
though they're about to explode
truly the mark of an advanced society
except for the panic zones
i have resigned myself to death although
i will miss
my friends and family when i'm gone that
guy is embarrassing himself
hey we're almost at the spaceport we
just have to smack this bad boy into the
hatch and we'll be done
you got this boy damn it
hey mission accomplished now let's get
back i got to watch some more hulu v
finally some answers about the pupa all
right
if your pupa turns orange it means it
ate something orange
oh well i did feed it a big bag of
doritos cheetos party blast you know
the same stuff the turmeric orange when
i ate it last year mmm so much dust
ugh that is a relief we aren't going to
get consumed by the pupa
at least not today and we changed the
past without creating a single
unintended butterfly effect so you know
we really slam dunked it hey look at us
we're ballers
we are ballers just then
another slurpee and vambo khakis tucked
in publisher annoying voice walks in the
ship
hey buggers we're out of stella
so is somebody gonna go uh
replenish it wait what who who the
are you
holy there's an alien in our house
karen corvo standing and stunned we
noticed that the room is decorated
differently than it usually is vampo
starts folding and sorting a huge pile
of clothes quit
jerking around you two have chores to do
help me organize all of my vests
and fingerless gloves i thought you said
everyone got exploded
who are you and what are you doing in
our house uh
what are you talking about i'm van bo
we escaped schlorp together remember uh
doi points to a family photo the same
one we see in the opening credits that
shows corvo terry yummy like jesse and
now vambo is also there
vanbo am i saying that right vanbo
whoa corvo you're really putting
on the pounds pal you're looking like a
blue shrek
where's your donkey at blue
oh and shrimp oh no cherry
i broke your ps4 because i tried to cook
one of those
little pizzas in it you know those
delicious little pizzas
yeah little pizzas hey i i just got that
from the witch
you son of a okay what the is going
on
must have inadvertently changed
something in the past resulting in us
now being in a dark
deviant time stream one of the results
being that vambo apparently joined us on
our mission and has been living with us
the whole time
oh no hey man i
i can't live with this dude he's so
basic i i bet he has a true
oh oh man
i can't live with a guy that's basic i
bet but he has a true crime podcast
like like he does one listening cool
doing one
we have to go back to the past and undo
the wallet change which should
return us to the correct time stream and
that'll get rid of vambo
in in the previous time streams vanbode
surely died on schlorb so so
yes but this isn't about fixing vanbo
this this is about fixing the time
stream
yeah no yeah yeah the time stream is the
priority for sure but
you're sure vambo will die yes his body
will be vaporized by the asteroid
we're there's a knock at the door uh
guys hello terry you gotta get in the
kitchen bro and make me a lean pork
sandwich
i gotta upload the next app of my pod
bro
come on come on go go go go let's go
there's our stick now all we have to do
is hit the wallet back out
that should undo the changes of the time
stream we're heroes
total heroes
so jesse tell me about your day or
something
really yes well i found out lauren
started going
and who cares geez are you on your
zeriot or something
yeah but it has nothing to do with it i
just want you to like me without earning
it i want unconditional like
wait you care if i like you
that is so sweet i no i just
i just don't want to worry about you
stabbing me in the back with the crazy
sci-fi gone when i piss you off
what are you even talking about no i
don't know you
phone call for drama queen jeremy like
storms out leaving jessica confused the
time vortex
opens and terry and corvo step out
bamboo is there anyone named vambo here
i'm looking for a vanbo
what no yes oh right oh my god
baby he's out running an errand
hey vampo's back that's right
hey guys gather round great news i
traded the gold making machine for these
expensive rats he opens the container
door and two hissing glasses run out and
start biting at tearing corvo's feet
ah it didn't work corvo oh he's
alive my toes
see they love you already check it out
give them a little kiss
no rats get them away from me terry now
we go back to the city square carver and
terry step backward out of the time
vortex again
corvo kicks a rat back into it you
you can't go back to the present until
we figure out how the hell vanvo keeps
surviving planetary destruction
uh i i don't even remember living with
the guy man
who thought time travel would be so
convoluted time travel should be clear
and linear
this isn't my fault well it's not my
fault oh look hey
it's the past meeting for the first time
oh look at that
they greet each other i am pleased to
embark on this mission with you
i assume you love science and worship at
the altar of logic oh yeah
science rules i love that stuff and i'm
a pupil expert
i know everything about the pupa terry
you follow past me and i will follow
past you no i want to follow past me
terry since neither of us remember
meeting vambo we we must both be outside
observers for each other
i will see you at the space all right
sounds good
i'm i'm young again honey can you help
me unload these groceries from the
piggly wiggly
mama you're so beautiful oh
well that's a nice thing to say i've
missed you so much when lorraine and her
mother hug
opera music begins to play lorraine
pulls herself back to look at her mother
who is now a young girl like herself
republic even further revealed young
lorraine and young jaclyn are in a field
of flowers
come run with me in a phase four saul
bass style sequence jacqueline and
lorraine clasp hands begin running
through the flowers
they dig their feet in the ground
raising their hands to the sky and
changing the flowers themselves
we follow the flower roots down to the
earth all the way to the red hot molten
core the magma shifts to look like the
red and pink folds of a brain
the folds of the brain ripple and become
waves in the ocean then a flock of
seagulls
we zoom in on a feather and we zoom out
again the feather is laying on the palm
of adult jaclyn's hand she hands it to
lorraine who is maybe five or six while
the two play at the beach
we go back to the white space the smile
on lorraine's mother fades she is now an
old woman again looking at the giant
pupa tears stream down her face
oh my sweet mother now that i remember
her face
i shall be able to find her when i'm in
heaven
i can die now knowing that everything
will be
okay oh thank you
there has to be some way i can repay you
for this
in my kitchen there's a cabinet with a
child proof lock
inside are two double-a batteries and a
harry potter whistle
get them for me you want
batteries and
a harry potter whistle
oh man you were right i'm not nice this
sucks i thought i was great
yum yulak my friend recognizing you suck
is the first step towards de-suckifying
okay face tell me how to be nice to
jesse and do it yesterday
well we usually just hang out at her
favorite place
oh my god this is so dumb welcome to the
pasteur pasteurized yogurt parlor the
world's first louis pasteur themed
yogurt shop what's up todd
you flash heatin that milk so it's safe
to drink yo
that's what pasteurization is my
[Music]
exchange man complicated handshake this
is so rich
jesse is such a loser shut your
face
mouth hole that's something i would say
you are like me i am not now
i'm going to show you how to be nice
aisha give us a little jesse hologram up
in this business
okay a hologram jesse appears hey
jesse you smell great today why don't we
all sample some flavors together thanks
best friend
i'm gonna try measles inoculation
pineapple die
me first freeze program yum baby you are
so not money right now
do you really think it was nice telling
her to die
yes no it was me hey you tricked me okay
let's just go back to the basics just
try smiling at me i mean like tries to
smile but it looks like a stroke
[Laughter]
oh this is gonna be a long night we
better put on a pot of hologram coffee
oh soil the womb in which we grow her
secrets never cease to delight me
what a dark work relaxation period
commencing work colleagues i just met my
assigned pupa specialist and he is
handsome he's gonna say handsome an
idiot
just look at that stupid face he
probably doesn't even know his floor of
ax array from
his garrito phase oscillator the gor
cortrino is gorrito
i want taco
[Music]
am i right all the other scientists
laugh out loud they clearly love purple
and think he's hilarious
unbelievable
place your pupa in a one centimeter deep
pool of pigment
and let it ink itself for three hours
past terry takes a seat next to a
feminine alien terry
t-e-r-i and puts his arm around her
corvo follows and sits behind them
what up terry i missed you babe miss you
little boo-boo you mean a little boo-boo
girl
good grief that smoke show is terry's
life mate
and it's also named terry how has he
never mentioned this
oh man i just met my evacuation partner
total derf sucks that i can't take you
instead of his boring flat ass
nasty ass ass the giant face notices
past terry isn't paying attention number
be quiet also button your top button
but i look way cooler this way
conformity
is cool the other people specialists
start chanting conformity conformity is
cool
conformity is
cool yes jesse your choice of vanilla is
fine and not for babies
no you can't wait you did it
aisha analyze malice no malice detected
oh i did it congratulations yamulac
for all your hard work i'd like to
reward you with a sticker of your
favorite avenger
oh hell yeah hawkeye he's got a quiver
his real name is clint
[Laughter]
my superpower is aim aim it you aiming
you
aim at you amen you oh
you're gonna sleep like a log tonight
ew when's the last time you cleaned out
the wall
it's been getting super gross in there
ever since they invented religion
jesse hello i wanted to greet you and
tell you that your bow
looks nice it wait
is this a trap cause you have to tell me
if it's a trap
i came in here to compliment you you did
yes and i did it gotta go before i mess
it up you look great bye
[Music]
you son of a oh yeah well guess
what you
suck you wanted to bring your stupid
life mate to earth huh
you you think terry with an eye is
better than me
you think i have a stupid face and that
i don't know what i'm doing with the pew
pipe
you don't
well i did it i was nice to jesse i'm
the nicest you've ever met
oh this is
wonderful thank you so much for spending
all that time making me a better alien
and now that i'm nice i can delete your
ass he opens a panel on the wall
hey deleting someone isn't nice yeah i
know
but i never want jesse to find out that
i needed training wheels for this stuff
so
you got to get trashed well it was a
pleasure teaching you
you know i actually learned something
from you too
oh yeah what was that how to be a dick
eat my finger
one of yamilak uses a hollow coconut to
bash the other's head in this should
look
truly disturbing when his head caves in
oh my god what the hell jesse's finally
getting the brother she deserves
we go now to the spaceport act three
terry and corvo break up their fight
they're both bruised and out of breath
all right all right all right okay all
right all right all right okay enough
we're done the partnership is over
agreed
when we get back to our time i'm packing
up and move into san diego
i'm gonna rent a condo in the gas lamp
and eat fish tacos every day and never
think of you
the sooner the better you and i have
never done anything good together
just then past jessie and pass yemi like
enter the hangar they greet past terry
and pass corvo
oh wow look how cute the replicants are
oh yeah they really are
we're all cute would you look at us two
regular aliens with their replicants
thinking that they're going to go into
space and terraform a rogue moon or
something
we had no idea what we were in for
you know terry we spent so much time on
earth pretending to be a family
didn't even notice when we actually
became one yeah i think we sealed the
deal on that when we
all saw mission impossible ghost
protocol
you remember tom cruise tc
terry i think you're right we all really
like that movie
hey remember when we made a crazy fun
bucket and it went crazy and attacked
the town yeah
that was awesome hey what about that
time we built the man cave
oh you had to bury the cockroam out
in the backyard
oh he loved it or remember that day when
everything was a musical
yeah or what about when we teamed up
with the simpsons for a game against the
monsters from space jam
vervo looks a past corvo and pat terry
with the past replicants
you know we may not have chosen each
other terry
but we've built a good life i i don't
want to throw that away
neither do i corvo neither do holy
terry sees past bamboo walking in
talking on a geode like it's a cell
phone hey
did you peep that photo of my mound i
sent you
pretty tight am i right what do you mean
you hated it you don't want a photo of
my
tiny hairless mound didn't you see the
crust
it's primo crust
that's bamboo and this is our chance to
set things right
he hit him with the time stick the what
now the retouch your stabilizer
oh yeah duh okay right harry pulls out
the stick from vambo's perspective the
floating stick
really smacks in the side of the head
is on the ground envelope hello hello
what's happening
vambo grabs a long space branch off the
ground and starts defending himself
against the stixx attacks he gets to his
feet and unitary and corvo all have a
big lightsaber-esque battle with their
stick weapons across the floor of the
spaceport
we go back to uh the actual mall jesse
funny like arrive at the real yoga
parlor real todd is there
wait this is where you want to take me i
thought
you said frozen yogurt was ice cream for
narcs
oh it is but now i'm nice to you which
means eating disgusting cold slime even
if it tastes like dust
are you feeling okay yum yulak oh yeah
please go ahead of me in line
i would be happy to hold your purse
while you sample some flavors
you're offering to hold my purse
correct well i go first of course
well okay that sounds great let me just
um it's in here
yeah jesse grabs a pink pocket knife out
of her purse and slits funny leg's
throat he falls
to the ground bleeding todd looks on an
horse oh my god what's wrong with you
don't worry that's not my brother it's a
pretend-a-duck stimulation that's
transferred his consciousness to a 3d
printed body and is trying to take his
place
oh jesse why i was
he gurgles dies and goes gray oh i'm
calling the police
don't move jesse takes out a ray gun and
zaps funny-looks body he
turns into a game boy cartridge which
she slides into a pocket
you turned him into a gameboy cartridge
just forget what you saw here sir
i can't it's so specific you go to the
pretender deck
jesse enters the pretender deck runs the
closet it opens it yummy like is lying
on the ground
ah please wake up i'm so sorry i created
fonule
you can be kind of a jerk sometimes but
you're my brother and i love you
yes he kisses yummy like's head his eyes
flutter open hi
jesse would you like to continue our
discussion of who is hotter
peta or gail or we can play maul madness
and practice our dance moves
jessie's face falls she drops funny luck
you're not
yomulac you're fun you look
funny like gets up flickering slightly
confirming that he has a computer
simulation he smiles at her
thank you for those sweet sweet kisses
freeze program freeze
program run me like freezes oh god no
i killed him you like i killed yummy
wack and turned his body into a gameboy
cartridge just like that fork and
cookies said i would
we go back to the spaceport in the past
the battle continues between terry corvo
and pass bamboo they fight across the
platforms
finally terry and corvo knocked the
wrench out of past bamboo's hands and
jab the stick through his chest
[Music]
who's the blue shrink now darren
corvo continue
mercilessly beating him blood splatters
on their faces they're really going
overboard
yeah yeah tell him that guy hey
look we got to get rid of the body man
do you have that thing that turns them
into game boy cartridges oh
no i see i never bring it when i end up
needing it i use the stick to push
vambo's body over the ledge
remember terry we're heroes we go back
to the living room day terry and corvo
step out of the vortex they look at the
family photo on the wall it's back to
normal
we did it vanvo's gone we repaired the
time stream
this is very good they start whooping
and jumping for joy but then something
outside makes a noise and the whole
house shakes
terry cover run out of the house but
then they pause huh
it appears we may have slightly altered
the time stream
um well it's not so bad i mean i can
live with this as long as bamboo's not
around suddenly there's a lot roar and a
slurping spaceship lands on top of the
house next door the ship patch
opens vambo steps out hello
buckers
vanvo what are you doing here your ass
should be dead as hell
should be dead as hell but i was rescued
and nursed back to health by a very
special
person terry's old life mate from sharp
steps off the ship
gary terry with an eye what the heck are
you doing here
i'm like vambo's science partner now and
my name's not terry with an eye anymore
it's van bye also spelled with an eye
that's so cool god damn it
see we've been searching the galaxy for
you
two nuts i know you guys attacked
me
with your time stick when we were on
shore we uh
uh we we don't know what you're talking
about oh you don't why don't you
shut up i have some very important news
to tell you
get ready schlorp never
blew up what
what did you hear the dramatic sting
i've come to take
both of you back so you can be tried and
executed
for using or retouch your stuffalizer
without a license what
cardinal i killed yummy lack and turn
his body into a gameboy cartridge he's
gone forever
what what oh
and um one more thing
after we all leave i'm gonna blow up
this stupid
earth planet just because
uh that's how vampo do
this can't be happening why
why is this happening wait
she's right this can't be happy but it
is well doesn't it seem like too many
big crazy events all at once
i mean i i know that's not how life
works man
no no no no no this doesn't feel real
okay okay okay this guy this guy has
lost it everybody gather round we're
going to watch this guy
his pants don't you see the time
traveling dead yumilac shlorp didn't
explode
i mean come on that's like it's just
it's so much stuff think about it that's
like way too much stuff that's
i mean if you had a list it's too much
too much
i mean it is sort of contrived you know
right i mean how are we sure we're not
in a matrix no hold on i gotta get it
right
right i mean how are we sure we're not
in other matrix
or a matrix reloaded because there would
be green numbers floating all around and
leather sunglasses
well it's got to be something okay and i
can figure this out i mean
we could be in an existence type sitch
stop it
last week you thought we were in an
existence because the drive-through gave
us an extra order of fries
we we can't be in an existence every
time you're freaking out
oh really smart guy but you're telling
me
that we have time traveling shoes that
we can use whenever we want
you're also wanting to know stuff about
the pupa why haven't you been using
those shoes man
why haven't you been using those shoes
i'm sure there's a logical explanation
for that no there isn't shut up everyone
shut the up
we've gotta be in some up strange
days
altered states lawnmower man horton
hears a who thing
maybe we're like in a tron don't don't
egg him on
this isn't a tron oh maybe we're in a
dream
yes yes now you're talking i mean i i
think we're all in some crazy dreamscape
style
inception what dreams may come joseph
and the music technicolor dreamcoat
zork the game dream
that's impossible nobody traps corvo in
a church we dream of win huh
wake up wake up stop that vambo slaps
corvo
wake up you have to wake up don't touch
me van vote
stop everyone is slapping corvo now
who's yelling and crying
wake up i'm awake wake up wake up wake
up carmel come on you can do it open
your eyes damn it
wake up come on do it wake up
[Music]
wake up i'm trying oh uh how long have
you guys been on the pretend today
ha i knew it none of that stuff happened
yes
people crawls in through the open door
happily playing an annoying harry potter
whistle that lights up and spins and
plays a harry potter type song
what the well how does the pupa keep
getting that harry potter whistle
i thought we lost does he keep getting
that thing don't everybody look at me
you obviously gave it to him i did not
damn it terry
you've got to stop raising false alarms
about the pupa you're making me google
i'm gooblering oh okay all right
weird he's never done that before pupa
stop that
the pupa looks at yummy like and jesse
do you think we should tell terry and
corvo
nah they're already all wound up but
what if he evolves and kills all of us
yeah right like that'll ever happen
see you next season everyone
and that's it guys that was a great
rehearsal let's jump back to the top
uh let's uh get it right this time